latest
partially cloudy skies with
some breezy winds out of it
sure if you enjoy the short flight up
for this today
the web
never got no wedding we only used the
forest to build our own houses garden
and we collect bark and leaves for our
medicine it is a great provider conectar
la mech e 22 grew up in the rainforest
owned by his clan in a mallu on the Fiji
Islands in its untouched state it plays
an invaluable role in protecting both
climate and biodiversity he and his clan
are taking part in a pilot project to
protect their rainforest
they're familien first and austin 4
million from the head of the emma lou
land owner families told me they had
three offers from logging companies
trying to obtain licenses so there is
some debate within the association about
whether to protect the forest or open it
up to commercial use not harvesting
timber implies a loss of revenue which
has to be compensated yeah a company at
velma's
another forest and another approach
the villagers of nuh kavu have opted for
the lucrative commercialization of their
forest resources but they're logging
trees both selectively and sustainably
they do what they can to protect the
sensitive ecosystem the session is
called directional felling which means
that you always determine which way the
tree is going to fall so it can be
removed without causing excessive damage
to the forest for some years young
hedrick hoffman has been hoping for
international support from the
compensation mechanism red for reducing
emissions from deforestation and
degradation diesel sung by the Moreta
seems the idea behind red is that you
try to create additional sources of
revenue in this case carbon credits that
give the village additional cash for
preserving the forest invite
the forest owners of a mallu discussed
the pros and cons of the red mechanism
for over a year the German agency for
international cooperation the GI said
works with the Fiji forest ministry to
help protect the Pacific Islands forest
from degradation and loss of carbon
stock namiki 22 s clan has also joined
in but they expect something in return
tyldus would project is part of this
pilot project is to determine how
international red funding can be
distributed from national levels to
forest owners and users who commit to
climate protection stimpy mush with
sweden Fiji's forest owners recently
received support for planting sandalwood
but it will be at least 15 years before
they begin to reap rewards we we know
that the project is gonna take some time
but really just same in the end owners
need something at least for their daily
activities and your further the living
in the minutes Fiji is not the only
island state hoping for support in
forests and climate protection the GI
said project director has turned down
several smaller Pacific nations their
forested areas are just too tiny to make
the red initiative worthwhile but all
parties agree that as the biggest
polluters the industrialised countries
have an obligation to act now it is a
moral and ethical
you don't have to be told no if you know
you're partly responsible way you must
play a role and I don't think you need
to be told to do that
nuh kavu is poised to started second
sustainable timber harvest this dakwah
tree alone is where its some 4,000 euros
for the red project forest inventories
are carried out to determine the forest
total carbon stock and to calculate the
exact number of carbon credits the
radisson z is equal to G Duncan red is a
very good concept and if it fails I
don't think it's going to be because of
the projects here but to the lack of
international political consensus which
prevents pledged funding from being paid
on I'd say that's the crucial point
libecki to to the head of the forest
owners clan of Emma Lou can do nothing
now but wait and trust that the
international community will fond read
thereby keeping its promise to
developing countries such as Fiji
you